have you ever stolen something they
don't press that yeah yeah someone's
girlfriend
[Music]
I'm well and these are the shocking
questions I'm eight ten years on my
shocking answers if you switch genders
for a date was the first thing you would
do
whoa take naked selfies what's your
least favorite musician of all time
I don't well that's the thing have you
ever stolen something they don't press
that yeah yeah someone's girlfriend
what is something no one else knows
about you well if that was the case
everyone had no will
so when was the last time you orgasm a
couple of seconds oh okay right here's
the person you're most proud to have as
a follow on social media as a follower
as a follower yeah I was gonna say I
chairman what achievement doesn't
actually follow me I'm proud of storms
er um let's go with storms there what's
your best chat up line you're not
dealing that with winner just call you
in will ya everyone to take all my girls
have you ever been starstruck
uh no never honestly I don't know maybe
if I see jay-z if he 50-cent yeah pablor
bored nah I don't fit anyone will meet
mr. Shaw I set for my month when I look
in the mirror you don't cry what is the
most embarrassing thing you've ever done
yo is it safe for my guy he shaking but
you don't fail fridge
I'm trying to get was all right next one
what was your dream job growing up as a
kid
Oh my dream job from there yeah there
was a little phase I want it to be a
kickboxer what no they don't make Morna
and I just thought wow that's much
better and then before I actually
realize what I wanted to do I blew up
hmm so I'm still deciding yeah yeah
basically what's the worst gift you've
ever received a new day with you know
until the last question so what is your
most disgusting habit well that has got
so much worse it's the start so well no
it's all right yeah yo my like wills
just risked his life for man telling
wealthy Danger Danger Danger